étranger
[Musique]
Je peux t'entendre être calme maman
j'espère que je n'ai pas gelé ton jeu mec
personne de mon âge ne dit ces mots dans cet
ordre
c'est juste difficile de voir mon petit homme ne pas
être mon petit garçon tout le temps
pendant des années  Je me suis occupé de ce
petit garçon
en veillant à ce qu'il soit aimé
qu'il se sente comme si il appartenait à l'endroit où
il voulait être,
il voulait aller dans le monde et faire de
grandes choses
pas mal
et ce qui m'inquiète le plus
j'aime  vous
miles c'était ils ne s'occuperont pas de vous comme
nous
miles
veux sortir d'ici
où que vous alliez d'ici vous devez
promettre de prendre soin de ce petit garçon
pour moi
il n'oublie jamais d'où il vient
[Musique]
et
il  ne doute jamais qu'il est aimé
et il ne laisse jamais personne
lui dire qu'il n'a pas sa place là-bas
tu dois promettre des miles
je promets
[Musique]
nous sommes censés être les bons gars nous
sommes
[Musique]
étrangers